this is from a National Review lawyer
for pregnant NYC nurse involved in bike
Feud vows to sue media for defamation
can I give you money sir I know they
have a GoFundMe for her but I would
provide some money for a lawsuit against
the media for a lying the lawyer
representing a pregnant New York
physician
assistant who whose confrontation with a
group of black men over rented bike led
to her suspension from the hospital
plans to sue media altitude that cast
her as a racist Thief
Sarah Jane comrade got into an argument
last week with a few young black men who
claimed she was stealing a rental bike
they paid for video went viral this we
know she then released receipts NBC News
reviewed them too so now they've been
reviewed by everybody and they've all
confirmed that yep that was her bike
they even gone so far as to say you
can't rent the same bike out in Rapid
succession meaning the only way she had
the receipt is if she was the one who
was trying to get the bike in the first
place these dudes were trying to rob her
and the media attacked her Ben Crump you
got a suit what's this guy's name what's
his lawyer's name Ben Crump no no this
this lawyer for Sarah comrie Justin
Mourinho you gotta Sue Ben Crump yup for
defamation yeah
yeah so they say a few minor press
outlets and uh and the black men
involved in the altercation claimed that
Camry was fake crying and stole the bike
multiple major press Outlets also
reported the video suggested she stole
the bike some online figures disparaged
comrade as a Karen a popular slang term
for a white woman who feels entitled to
special treatment we are going to get an
answer when we start filing defamation
lawsuits Marina told Fox news's Bill
hemmer she's been called a racist a
thief there are reasons defamation laws
exist and we plan to pursue that well
there is the a lot of the headlines on
Twitter it said appears to be stealing a
bike and it's like that word appears
it's literally prevent it's like the
shield preventing you from your live
from your from your lawsuit right so
like I said no matter how much you hate
the journalists you don't hate them
enough you really should hate them more
you cannot you can't hate them enough
they I love the Michael malice uh quote
about you know the job will be done when
the average journalist is looked at like
a tobacco lobbyist
that's the that's the respect they
deserve are disgusting they want the
they want the race war yeah they can't
come soon enough the thing is like I I
know I talked about this on Twitter the
other day um there was this this uh and
then the ndaa of uh 2012 the Smith
modernization Act of 2012. that allowed
the federal government to propagandize
people that coincides with the like the
singularity of everybody having a cell
phone in their pocket and having the
Internet connected to them the media
jumped at the chance to feed the people
the story that the government wanted and
I can't like the reason that there's so
many people that feel very homogenized
one way is because the federal
government has been shoving a narrative
down our throats and it's it is
reflected in the way the population
looks at other people you look at the
way the left looks at the right the
whole like the uh what was it the the
not the disposables the deplorables and
all that stuff that goes along with it
they're just oh the race they're all
racist they're all this they're all that
and it's a narrative that is shoved down
everyone's throat like we were talking
earlier all the magazines are the same
it doesn't matter if it's GQ or if it's
time or if it's rolling stone they're
all shoving the same message down their
throat team Vogue the federal government
exactly yeah giving young women
communism since like back for back for
years exactly and the narrative that's
coming out of the federal government is
oh there's all these it's the white
nationalism is the white nationalism is
the biggest problem in your your Maga
neighbor is probably a racist that hates
you and Etc et cetera all of that is a
propaganda message that is coming
straight out of the federal government
directed at the left because that's the
quote unquote nice uh opinion and it's
also the one that actually empowers the
government so of course the federal
government is going to promote a
narrative that promotes P that says
people should endorse what the federal
government wants you know higher taxes
and and more power and authority to the
federal government so I I think that the
that has been a big part of the reason
why everyone's seen everyone on the left
seems to have the same opinion and knows
nothing about the right they don't know
anything about independence they only
know that the the what the left has been
told you know told to think essentially
I think too you know no one wants to
talk about it especially on the right
but there is 100 percent a racial caste
system that currently exists in this
country I mean this woman was
villainized she was called a burglar
every name in the book right because
she's the caricature of a Karen which is
a slur for white women who dare to you
know complain about the degeneracy that
they see in their communities
um that that just you know say I don't
want it to be this way and I think they
tried to Daniel Penny her they really
did they tried to throw her under the
bus she was fired from her job or I
think placed on yeah placed on leave
from her job
um and the media came after her and you
know who was in docs the people who
attacked her I mean it's just totally
backwards the media is out there
defending criminals Lawless gangs just
that are running the streets and I think
our law enforcement too you're seeing
selective enforcement here right you
have people that are allowed to behave
in a criminal Manner and then you have
people who aren't and often that is
whether you are right or left leaning
what does it matter when the prosecutors
when the DA's won't prosecute anyways on
a lot of these crimes doesn't matter no
it's crazy I mean we used to arrest
people for disturbing the peace and now
if you walk around no we did and now if
you walk around do you see yeah now if
you walk around DC there are homeless
people screaming and harassing you at
almost every corner that is interesting
I was looking at these photos
we were in Atlantic City and they have
these photos all on the wall at this one
uh this where this playset in photos and
all and you could see everybody wearing
a suit like it's the boardwalk 1920 or
whatever and all the men and women are
dressed up and I was like they're
wearing three-piece suits the women are
all wearing this crazy outfit I'm like
that's kind of crazy they would arrest
you for disturbing the peace like very
rigid way of living I'm not advocating
for it but I am saying we used to have a
little bit more rules maybe we need a
little bit more rules it's a slippery
slope you gotta stop wearing the
three-piece suit out in public and all
of a sudden there's just crime going on
in the streets you stop wearing a
three-piece suit next thing you know is
a dude taking a dump right there in the
middle of the street that's how they
don't arrest these people
because you can't because they're
they're mentally or you know they're
mentally ill and and
they should be institutionalized well
yeah the state at least at this point
the state can't just pick them up so I
mean there probably should be some kind
of law that even that I have a problem
with because like look the second you
throw somebody in the system let's not
pretend like any of these institutions
uh as soon as they get a hold the system
gets a hold of them it's very hard to
extricate yourself from that environment
because they're so corrupt so I'm that
this came up a lot when they were
talking about Britney Spears because
she's still acting absolutely ridiculous
I'm like it's her right to do that she's
not harming she's not harming anyone
she's not making good decisions but it
is her right as an American citizen to
make those bad decisions for herself but
the people that are doing these things
in the streets are doing things that are
harming other people but I still would
err on the side of caution of just
throwing them in asylums given that I
don't know if that's the answer yes but
hear me out I have an idea what if
in San Francisco
if you are caught taking a dump
outside
they put you on a boat and bring you to
an island and then leave
so an island maybe in the Bible
but I'm not saying any prosecution I'm
saying if you are caught defecating in
the streets they put you on the boat
they bring you out they drop you off on
the island you're free to go they have
like no no there's no incarceration
you're not locked up they're just gonna
we're gonna drop you off right here and
that's it no more words I'm not here to
insult you we'll be on our way and if
you build a boat and come back from the
island then so be it otherwise
you know you're not locking anybody up I
mean you could you're not depriving them
of anything if they don't if they don't
live anywhere if they're if there's if
they're if they're homeless with no jobs
and they're taking dumps on the street
why should in all seriousness the
question is this why should we as
Citizens and taxpayers of a city
tolerate people who aren't members of
our community
destroying our community right do we not
have the right to be like we are going
to place you outside you can always walk
back in we're not like but if we catch
you we're going to remove you again
because I know people who've gotten
banned from cities I've heard this
they're like you're not welcome here and
things like that but we don't do it for
people taking dumps in the street in San
Francisco yeah I assume they want that
though like the government likes that
it's happening they could arrest them
though and prosecute them but they won't
prosecute them and that's the big
problem here right what are they doing
at Epstein's Island they could use that
one there's Alcatraz is in San Francisco
Alcatraz just right out there it's
already there's buildings just don't
lock them up but there's already
buildings they can go inside they can
Shelter From the rain
if we give them like a big enough island
with like food and animals and stuff
it's like you have every chance to
survive in in this and it's a mini Exile
it's like mini it's like you can always
come back just swim I don't know
whatever it's up to you we're not we're
not telling you what you can or can't do
we're just leaving you here the island
to Catalina off of uh yeah there's a
fantastic reality show pitch in there
somewhere
we placed 100 homeless men on an island
like if MILF Banner is a thing then they
could absolutely do that for the number
one for the number of homeless people
that are in I mean just the greater San
Francisco area you need you'd need an
island the size of like Oahu like it
would have to be like a size the
question is
is it possible that what these people
might need is actual hardship
I mean probably they are where these are
people who are in places where they have
makeshift shelters free everything they
get money from the state they get they
get money and if they don't people are
giving them food they're getting food
somewhere somehow so there's no
requirements yeah this isn't it's an
it's enabling it's not helping them what
if the one thing these people need is
just to be in open land and say figure
it out and then all of a sudden they're
like hey I'm not getting food anymore I
better find food and then it starts
giving them responsibility and helping
them you know survive I'm not so so
confident that would work but I do think
there is value to the idea that human
beings are anti-fragile so we respond
well to adversity like literally our
bodies need gravity
to have for our bones to have the
Integrity to to hold our body together
so like we need to go and exercise to
keep our bodies in shape and we need to
have that resistance we need to strive
for things to feel like we are
accomplishing things that's something
that's important for human beings so I
don't know if I I don't know that I
agree that we can just go and toss them
into the Wilderness but I do think that
there is Merit the idea that human
beings need adversity to flourish the
homeless problem is one of the hardest
ones to discuss right because it gets
into the idea of body sovereignty it
gets into the idea of free will but then
you have to have these discussions where
they say oh just throw them in a hotel
just give them a hotel and everything
will be fined and the hotel is destroyed
two days later and it's one of the
hardest ones to discuss because there
really isn't a clean solution to any of
it yours might be the cleanest solution
to that type of thing but that's just
for the ones that are actually doing
something that's harming the the quality
of life of somebody else what about the
ones that aren't like what do you do
then then what if we just say like we as
a city reserve the right to remove
people from our boundaries
yeah they will never do it I think the
people in these cities like it I mean
well they I think the people in these
cities aren't of most of the time
they're not affected right like so
if there's like a million people in the
city and there's a thousand homeless
people that's a lot of homeless people
but it's not enough to have a negative
effect on everybody's life every day
enough where they're gonna be like hey
this is a big deal that's that's one of
the things I said in La is I said there
I saw this guy in a he was clearly
disabled he's driving driving a little
scooter thing uh I couldn't tell if he
was a paraplegic or quadriplegic but he
couldn't use the sidewalk that was built
for him in order to get down the street
because there's literally so many
encampments so he's driving on the road
and cars are like dodging him down 6th
Street it's just like yeah I thought you
guys were about you know caring for
people that are disabled and Etc but
you're not okay here's another idea what
if
we take homeless people there like after
after a certain amount of infractions
maybe three
if they're sleeping outside and it's
like hey you can't sleep outside this is
your first warning don't do it again
then we catch them like defecating it's
like look this is your second time third
time you know it's gonna happen third
time they get placed in government
housing where their food and shelter is
taken care of they will be clothed and
fed but they have to do work that we
prescribe and they're not allowed to
leave
Three Square meals a day I've heard of a
place
no I I do I mean there's How about if
someone takes a crap on the street we
prosecute them and put them in jail you
think that I think so what do you think
I mean absolutely yeah that would be
ideal but unfortunately that's not the
way that our society or legal system is
currently running and I think people
have come to accept this as The New
Normal yeah I mean so many young people
that I meet in DC in cities like Chicago
or New York they don't know any
different this is this is what they're
used to you see it's so sad at the
Oscars this year like they just put up
big fake walls so that you couldn't see
the homeless people well the celebrities
were walking down that is the gross that
is the grossest thing
that is it's the most nimbing thing in
the world it is so gross they just clear
them out for a couple of days they're
like you can come back after the event
you know what I think benefited me
greatly as a kid is that I went to
Catholic school for the from
kindergarten I was homeschooled then I
went to Catholic School from
kindergarten until fifth grade started
sixth grade at Public School those kids
in public school did not know it was
possible the kids at the Catholic school
I felt were very like hoity-toity and
like very high strung but at the
Catholic School everything's more
ordered yep I went to Catholic School
from from kindergarten until uh seventh
grade or say no yeah seventh grade so
there's a lot of people who don't know
that things can be really really good
they don't they they never they've never
experienced they don't know it's
possible Well yeah if you if you're born
into that environment you just adjust to
it accordingly and then you never really
look outside that they talk about a lot
of people who grew up in inner cities
who never who never travel more than a
couple blocks from their house they've
never seen any and that's just that's
something you could get away with in a
car right like they could drive to get
there but they don't drive you know
they've never owned a car they've never
been someplace other that shows them
that there's more things that are
possible that's kind of where in a lot
of ways I feel like a lot of that the um
how we talk about going away to college
like that's what that's become for a lot
of for a lot of kids like they get a
scholarship because they want to go away
and experience something different of
course colleges now are not exactly what
they used to be but a lot of people just
they never learn that there is a world
outside of what they're used to
yeah
yep and then what ends up happening is
they keep voting for what they think is
the only thing it's the funniest thing
to me we had Lance on and um the
conversation around Daniel penny and I
don't know if it was him but uh it might
have been AOC saying something like
you know the the right keeps blaming
mental illness for all these things when
the Republicans defund these mental
illness blah blah I'm like what
Republican is running New York City
this is this is run by like all of these
issues black lives matter police it's
all Democrat cities it's the craziest
thing to me when they're like we want to
defund the police I'm like yeah okay
y'all are in a Democrat Democrat City
defunding the places no no issue does
nothing to my Sheriff's Department I
don't care yeah the left is complaining
about
what they voted for it is the it is the
craziest thing as well they're in
democrat-run cities complaining about
problems that are born of their policies
it's like watching a toilet get flushed
and I'm just sitting there being like
there it goes they just it's just
spinning around and around around they
keep doing the same thing and then
complaining about it I remember arguing
with kids in L.A that were saying like
oh it's still these all these Republican
Senators these Republican congressmen
like there's numerous Senators do you
understand how many there are like you
don't have any idea dude you're in L.A
yeah Senator can't change what's
happening in La that's your city
government
people are so ignorant about the about
what they are upset about yeah it's they
have no idea that the most effective
things that they can do are things that
they do locally you know the things that
are going to have the biggest impact on
their daily lives are going to be things
that they you know can do locally Joe
Biden is not going to be able to do
anything and it isn't interested in
doing anything to make your life better
like not at all so to and I really wish
that you could get people to like not
just hear that but actually internalize
and be like all right if I want to make
my life I want my life to be better I
have to do things whether it be acting
locally or maybe it's it's you know
taking some you know taking some agency
in your own life and going out and
trying to do some stuff there's a lot of
people that have rough lives but they
also get so wrapped up in the fact that
their life is rough that they're not
gonna they feel like they can't do
anything about it so if you feel like
you have no agency and you can't do
anything you're not going to try in uh
in in Minnesota post George Floyd
um in uptown you know a lot of these
places were the same ones that held
events advertising defund the police you
know which leads to a lot of lawlessness
in the city and what would happen is
graffiti would be put up on all of the
buildings uh you know all of the shops
in uptown and then the city would come
through and they would say you need to
clean this up in the next seven days or
we're going to clean it up for you we're
going to charge you 700 800 to do it and
of course because you know the cops have
pulled back because of all of the
negative press that's going on at that
time graffiti goes up they get uh they
get hit with a 700 fine when somebody
has to come clean it up for them and it
never seems to make it to their brain
that you voted for the policies that are
enabling you going out of business they
don't understand that because I don't
know if they think that deeply Beyond
just either whatever the wedge issue is
and whatever the emotion that that very
skilled politician has done has been
able to do in making you feel angry
about it thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there